Hey everyone, Ryan here and welcome to this series on orthodontics.
So this is my personal favorite specialty since I'm currently studying orthodontics
as a resident.
We're going to cover a ton of great content.
The board examiners combine orthodontics and pediatric dentistry into one category in
their guidelines, but I think it's honestly more helpful to focus on each one individually.
I've already made the Pediatric Dentistry Series, if you want to go check that out.
So that being said, like all of my videos, I'm going to focus on the highest yield things
that you need to know for the exam and my hope is that these videos will help you prepare
for the board exam and also give you an overview for clinical application and general knowledge.
So we're going to start by talking about growth and development and I like to think of growth
and development as two sides of the same coin.
They are two distinctly different things, but they work in harmony towards the same goal.
So growth is all about an increase in size or number.
An increase in size of cells is called hypertrophy.
An increase in number of cells is called hyperplasia.
And growth has to do with anatomic things, height, weight, length, width.
They're all quantitative numbers.
Now development is an increase in complexity or specialization of functions, and this is
more physiological or behavioral.
So it's more qualitative things, day-to-day function, how you learn, how you act and behave,
and things like that.
Growth and development follow three basic laws.
There's a pattern, so their predictable changes in how a body will grow over time.
There's general timing, ages where we expect growth and ages where we don't, but there's
also some variability in how an individual person will grow and develop with time.
So there's a pattern, timing, and variability.
One such pattern is the cephalocaudal growth gradient.
So this is saying that body parts closer to the cranium grow fast early on while body
parts further from the cranium grow more later on.
So another way to think of it is the brain is the trailblazer and everything else has
to catch up later on.
So we can see some examples of this phenomenon in these pictures.
So two months in utero, this baby has a head that comprises 50% of its total length, but
once we get to three to four months in utero, now the head only comprises 30%.
At birth, the head is 25%, and then as an adult, the head is about 12% of the total height.
You can also look at the upper limbs versus the lower limbs, so the upper limbs grow more
earlier, and then the lower limbs have to catch up later on in life.
The same can be said for the maxilla and the mandible.
The maxilla will fully mature earlier than the mandible does because the maxilla is closer
to the cranium.
So one visual depiction of a typical growth pattern and timing of that pattern is the
scammon's growth curves.
So these growth curves show age on the x-axis in years and tissue size on the y-axis.
So from top to bottom we have the lymphoid growth curve, so that's your immune tissues,
the neural growth curve, so that's like your brain, then we have maxilla, mandible, general
body tissues like bones and muscles, and then finally genital tissues on the bottom.
So each of these has a unique pattern to it, and neural tissues, including the brain, grow
rapidly after birth, the steepest of these curves, and then reach near adult size by
about age 6 or 7, and then kind of levels out.
Lymphoid tissues also grow rapidly, reaching twice their adult size by age 10, so note
that this is a percent of adult size, and so we're actually surpassing what the lymphoid
tissue mass will be as an adult.
So we're way up here at about 10 years, and then they involute or shrink during the pubertal
growth spurt to reach their final growth adult size at 100%.
The genital tissues do not grow much at all until you hit the pubertal growth spurt, and
then they rapidly increase to that 100% adult size.
The general body tissues grow rapidly after birth, they kind of slow down in childhood,
and then grow rapidly again during the pubertal growth spurt.
And then finally we have the maxilla and mandible, and so the maxilla follows a bit closer to
the neural growth curve, because it's closer to the brain, and the mandible follows more
closer to the general growth curve, because it's further away from the brain.
So we see that cephalocaudal growth gradient manifesting in these really neat growth curves.
So notice how the lymphoid and genital curves after age 10, so if we mark off here and here,
they kind of act opposite to each other, they're like mirror images, the lymphoid goes way
down, and the genital goes way up during that growth spurt, and that's because as the concentration
of sex hormones estrogen and testosterone increases, they drive the growth spurt, and
this inhibits the further growth of lymphoid tissue, which actually begins to shrink, eventually
reaching that normal adult size.
So Scammons is one way, and we also have distant and velocity human growth curves to represent
growth over time.
So let's look at the distance curve first.
Now pediatricians often keep track of their patient's growth with charts.
The patient will stand against the wall, mark how tall they are, and that's your distance
curve in black.
It's showing how much size you've accumulated over time.
So that's never really going to go down, it's only going to increase.
The velocity curve in gray shows the rate of growth.
So if you remember in physics, it's showing the slope of the distance curve.
So if you have a big increase in a high slope in the beginning, that high slope is going
to be indicated by the velocity curve being way up here.
And then as that growth starts to taper off, our velocity curve shows that as well.
And then once we get to that growth spurt at around 12, 13, 14, we can see an acceleration
in growth and how the velocity increases to show that what's happening on the distance
curve.
So the distance curve tracks actual height each year while the velocity curve tracks the
change in height which allows you to more easily observe growth velocity like the growth spurt.
So these are specific velocity curves for boys and girls.
And it shows that girls hit their growth spurt earlier and mature earlier than boys do in
general.
And boys mature more and later on in their lifetime.
So the average peak growth for girls is at around age 12.
That peak growth time for boys is at around age 14 a little bit later.
Generally, the earlier your peak growth is, that means the shorter duration that growth
spurt will be and the less overall growth that you will see.
So we looked at some growth patterns and we talked about some of the things that happen
with specific tissues and humans and boys and girls.
Now let's talk more about timing of growth.
So there are a number of different things you can go off of to determine how mature someone
is.
The easiest thing would be to go up their chronologic age because everybody knows their age.
But that's often not a good indicator of maturity because there's variability.
Some people mature early, some people mature late.
So we have other things to help us judge just how mature that person is.
One of those things is dental age.
And this is based on their state of dental development, how many primary teeth they have,
how many primary teeth have exfoliated, how many permanent teeth have come in.
But this is unfortunately a pretty poor indicator of maturity.
The next thing we have is skeletal age, and this can be measured by two methods.
One of them is the CVM staging, which is the cervical vertebral maturation.
So you take a cephalometric x-ray, you look at how their cervical vertebrae are shaped
on that cephalometric, and that gives you an indication of how mature that individual
might be.
The other popular method is not as popular in any more, it is called the hand-risk method,
where you take an actual x-ray of that person's hand and you can look at the finger bones
and the wrist bones and see how those are developing to determine someone's maturity.
This is a better indicator of maturity, but not the best.
So biologic or developmental age is based on certain markers of maturation, like we can
see here, menarchy or first menstruation, which occurs just after the peak velocity
of growth.
Also, you can go off secondary sex characteristics like facial hair, and this is the best indicator
of an individual's growth status and maturity.
So we kind of go from worst to best in this list.
All right, so now let's talk about how does growth actually happen.
So we have growth sites, and we have growth centers.
So a site is any area where growth is occurring.
A center is a site of growth, so growth is occurring also at centers, but they also have
the ability to grow independently on their own.
So growth centers kind of have a mind of their own, and they can control their own growth,
and sometimes even control the growth of other growth sites.
As far as craniofacial structures go, most of the things we're going to be talking about
are sites.
The only true growth center is a synchondrosis.
Sutures, surfaces, and the mandibular condyles are all sites.
And we'll talk more about this a little bit later.
So there are two main modes of growth.
The first one is endochondrial ossification, which I equate with interstitial growth.
So this is growth from the inside, and it results in an increase in length of bones.
So we start with an embryonic cartilage model or template that grows first, and is eventually
replaced by bone.
So we have this zone of resting cartilage.
We're looking at an epiphyseal plate here, and the zone of resting cartilage is at the
very end of this bone.
So we're looking at an epiphysis, and this is the very end of that bone.
So the resting cartilage will have these small little chondrocytes, and they're really hard
to see here, but they're just these little tiny condrocyte cells nestled in cartilage.
Then we have this zone of proliferation.
And so we're getting hyperplasia, rapid mitotic division, and it results in these columns of
cells that are parallel with the direction of growth.
And this is contributing to that increase in length.
Then we get to the zone of maturation, where we see hypertrophy.
The cells are starting to get bigger, but the walls of the cells are getting thinner.
Then we get to the zone of calcified cartilage, or calcification, where mineral is deposited,
and the condrocytes are actually destroyed.
You can note that there are kind of outlines that are missing nuclei.
So now we have some dead cells, but with the beginnings of calcification and mineralization.
And then finally, we have the zone of ossification, where these empty spaces are invaded by capillaries
that form centers of ossification.
They dump off these progenitor cells that become osteoblasts that can secrete osteoid, which
eventually becomes bone.
So an endochondrosification bone develops from a pre-existing cartilage model, and it's under
more direct genetic control.
So we see this in epiphyseal plates of long bones, synchondroses of the cranial base,
and also in the condular cartilage of the mandible.
Now the other one here is the intramembranous ossification.
And this I equate with oppositional growth or mesenchymal growth.
And so this is growth from the outside, and it results in an increase in thickness or diameter.
So now we're looking at the sides of the bone, and as you get more circumferential lamella
laid down along the outside, you get more diameter.
And at the same time, bone is being resorbed by osteoclasts in the center, from the inside
in the medullary cavity.
So the bone growth stays proportional throughout childhood and adolescence.
So here osteoblasts are secreting their osteoid matrix directly within the connective tissue
lining, and then it calcifies without any intermediate cartilage at all.
So here bone develops from fibrous connective tissue, and it's influenced more from environmental
forces like stresses.
So this is what happens at your sutures or on the surfaces of the cranial vault, the
maxilla, and other craniofacial structures.
So we'll talk more about those specifics in a little bit, but I just wanted to lay the
foundation for endochondral, which you can kind of piece apart to mean within cartilage
and intermembranous within the membrane.
Those are two big, the two big modes of bone growth.
Now there are three different mechanisms that have been proposed for growth, and no one theory
explains all of craniofacial growth control.
So we kind of have to consider all three of these working in concert.
So Harry Sitcher came up with the suture theory.
This is where direct genetic control determines how bone is going to grow, and bone will determine
its own growth, and sutures act as growth centers that push stuff apart.
This one is mostly debunked as false, because we know that the growing brain pushes skull
bones apart, and new bone is laid down at the sutures in response.
So sutures aren't really -- they're more so reactive, they're not really proactive.
So their growth sites, they're not growth centers, as Harry Sitcher pointed out.
The James Scott came up with the cartilage theory, and this posits that epigenetic growth
control has cartilage pushing and pulling stuff apart.
So in the cartilage theory, cartilage is the growth center that determines growth,
and bone simply follows along.
Now this one definitely has some truth to it.
If we look at this example of a condler fracture, condler fractures usually happen on the condler
neck, on the side opposite to the side of impact, and then that disconnected condyle
gets pulled away, it gets absorbed, and then 75% of the time it regenerates, and 25% of
the time it doesn't, leading to growth problems like jaw asymmetry.
But how could it regenerate by itself if it didn't have some kind of intrinsic control?
So perhaps there is some truth that cartilage has some intrinsic growth potential.
And then Melvin Moss came up with the functional matrix theory, and this is where this is governed
by environmental growth control.
So chewing, speaking, and other functions cause the nasal and oral cavities to get bigger,
which serve as the primary determinants of growth for the maxilla and the mandible.
So here the soft tissue matrix determines growth, and bone and cartilage follow that.
So there's really good evidence for this, and it's what we use before to disprove the
suture theory, that the growing brain, which is a soft tissue, pushes those skull bones
apart, and the sutures are reacting to that pressure and laying down bone between those
skull bones.
So all three theories, even though suture theory is mostly disproved, work in concert
to describe the different mechanisms by which the craniofacial structures grow.
So some pretty cool stuff, and here are the five main regions of the cranium in face.
We have the cranial vault, the cranial base, the nasomaxillary complex, the mandible, and
then the two dentoalveolar processes supporting the teeth, and we'll go through how each
of those grows specifically.
So the cranial vault is the top part of the skull that encases the brain.
At birth, the cranial bones are widely separated by this loose connective tissue called fontanels.
So these wide spaces enable delivery of the baby through the birth canal.
Now, bone is laid down along the membranes of these bones, and that eventually will shrink
down these spaces, at which point they're called sutures.
So sutures are thinner spaces that separate the cranial bones in childhood, adolescence,
and then they eventually fuse later in adult life.
So as the brain grows, these cranial bones are being pushed apart.
And so in order to keep this space from opening wider and wider, new bone is being laid down
along these membranes, and that will occur at these sutures.
So this is an example of intermembranous ossification.
Intermembranous results in an increase in diameter, so the entire skull is getting wider
and wider, and the bone will be filling in at the fontanels and sutures to keep up with
the growing brain.
But also, you have direct apposition of bone outside of the skull and resorption or removal
of bone from the inside.
So if we go back to this image, you can imagine that in addition to what's happening at the
sutures, new bone is being laid down at the outside, which we call apposition, and bone
is being removed from the inside, which is called resorption.
So we're getting intermembranous ossification not only at the sutures, but also at the surfaces
as well.
The cranial base consists of the ethmoid, sphenoid, and occipital bones at the base of
the skull.
Now these three bones are initially cartilage.
They're part of the chondro cranium in the fetus, and they later transform into bone.
Now we're left, though, with three bands of cartilage that stick around that are important
growth centers called synchondroses.
So each synchondrosus acts like a two-sided epiphyseal plate that we saw before, so you
can imagine that there's this really tiny thin zone of resting cartilage in the center,
and then maturing cartilage is being pushed out in either direction in order to expand
the bone at that zone.
So these bones are being literally split apart from each other by the synchondrosus, which
continues to grow and increases the length of this structure.
So this is, of course, an example of endocondrel ossification, because we're dealing with a
cartilage model.
The intersphenoid synchondrosus will fuse and close first.
It's about inactive at by age three, sphenoid ethmoid by age seven, and spheno occipital
is the last one to become inactive.
Next let's talk about the maxilla.
So growth occurs at the sutures, posterior and superior to the nasomexillary complex
at its connections to the cranial vault and the cranial base.
So this area right here is this cranial base that we looked at right here.
It's kind of like a mid sagittal slice of the skull, and that's that component right
there.
The cranial vault is, of course, this part right here.
And so we're getting a position of bone at these sutures, because soft tissue, that's
the nasal and oral cavities which are expanding, are pulling this maxilla downward and forward
away from the cranial base.
Simultaneously, there's also surface remodeling that includes resorption of bone anteriorly,
an opposition of bone inferiorly at the palate, and then also at the alveolar ridges as the
teeth erupt down.
There's also addition of bone at the tuberosity posteriorly to make room for the second and
third molars.
So the ultimate result of all of this is a downward and forward translation of the maxilla
away from the cranial base.
The mandible has some interesting steps to it.
So it develops in the embryo just lateral to the cartilage of the first pharyngeal arch,
which is called meckles cartilage.
But the confusing part is that this is not endocondrel growth.
So meckles cartilage isn't being replaced by bone.
And the mandible, which is here, just happens to be created intermembranously right next
to it.
So meckles cartilage actually will disintegrate and contribute to the malleus, anchus, and
sphenomandibular ligament.
Now meanwhile, while this is going on, we have the condler cartilage, which develops
independently and later fuses with the developing mandibular ramus at about four months in utero.
So here we have the condler cartilage.
And here is the part that we were looking at right over here.
So although the cone-shaped cartilage is replaced by bone eventually, its upper end will persist
as a site for growth.
That condler cartilage we will see in the next slide.
So that mandibular condler cartilage proliferates and is transformed into bone as the mandible
grows downward and forward, again away from the cranial base.
So both jaws are being moved downward and forward, but by totally different modes or
mechanisms.
And this creates a gap between the two jaws into which the teeth can erupt.
Now in addition to this endochondral ossification occurring at the condler cartilage, we're
also getting surface opposition, which occurs along the posterior surface of the ramus to
try to match and keep up with what the condyle is doing.
You also get some opposition at the coronoid process as well as a little bit at the chin.
Surface resorption occurs along the anterior surface of the ramus, which makes room for
the second and the third molars to erupt, which is opposite with what was happening at
the maxilla where we had a position to give room for the second and third molars.
Whereas here we have to take bone away in order to free up a row for those second and
third molars to erupt.
Now just like the maxilla, you also get alveolar bone growth vertically as the teeth erupt
into position.
So we're getting in the mandible a mix of endochondral ossification and intermembranous
ossification.
Now as the mandible grows, it can stay at the same angle or it can tend to rotate because
it has this axis at the condyle.
So it can either rotate open in this direction or closed in this direction.
So an average growth rotation is where the condler growth roughly is equal to the amount
of molar eruption.
So the mandible truly just grows downward and forward at roughly the same orientation as
you can see here.
Now if we have a closing rotation or counterclockwise growth, that means that the growth of the
condyle is greatly exceeding the amount of molar eruption that we're seeing.
So that would lead to a shorter, lower anterior face height and a skeletal deep bite tendency.
The opposite is opening rotation or clockwise growth.
This is where the condyl or growth is less than the amount of molar eruption leading to
a long anterior face height and skeletal anterior open bite tendency.
So here's a summary of everything that we talked about.
The cranial vault, and we'll kind of focus mostly on this row here, mesenchymal is synonymous
with intermembranous.
So we're seeing intermembranous growth at the sutures in the surfaces, because there's
no cartilage in the cranial vault.
The cranial base, we see endocondral growth at the synchondroses.
We also have a nominal amount of intermembranous growth that happens laterally to make the cranial
base grow wider, but don't worry too much about that part.
The maxilla has purely intermembranous growth that's at both sutures and the surfaces directly
– again, no cartilage here.
And the mandible, we mostly get intermembranous growth at its surfaces, but we're also getting
endocondral growth at that condyle, which is pushing that mandible downward and forward,
which is a very important growth mechanism.
And of course, there are no sutures in the mandible, so that intermembranous growth is
purely at the surfaces.
The last high yield fact that I want to cover is a general trend.
Now we talked about all the different regions of the cranium in the face, and each of those
skull bones exists in three planes of space.
There's width, length, and height, or more commonly referred to as transverse, anterior
posterior, or AP, and vertical.
And these will come up all throughout the series.
But generally, the transverse dimension stops growing first at around age 10 to 12, then
AP at 14 to 16, and finally vertical at 18 to 20, or even further on into later adult
life.
There are exceptions to this, but this is the general overarching trend that drives many
treatment decisions that we'll cover later in the series.
So that's it for this video, thank you so much for watching, please like this video if
you enjoyed it, and consider subscribing to this channel for more on dentistry.
If you're interested in supporting this channel and what I do, please check out my Patreon
page, a huge thank you to all of my patrons for all of their support.
You can unlock extras like access to my video slides to take notes on, and practice questions
for the board exams with explained answers.
So go check that out, the link is in the description.
Thanks again for watching everyone, I'll see you in the next video.